So let's try a few examples. So we'll create a dictionary.
We're using the squiggly brackets. On some keyboards
that's the shift on the square bracket key. It may be somewhere else on your keyboard.
And we're going to use the squiggly bracket to list our elements in the dictionary.
So each element in the dictionary is a key value pair, and the entries in the dictionary
will be the elements and their atomic numbers. So we have this string hydrogen
with its atomic number of 1, and we have carbon with number 6.
So we've created the dictionary, and what we see when we print it out
is the elements in the dictionary. Now one thing you might notice is
they're not in the same order that we put them there. If you think about what we did
with hash tables, this isn't so surprising. When we put elements in hash tables,
well where they end up in the hash table depends on the key and the hash function.
It's not necessarily in the order that we put them in. And with the dictionary,
because it's implemented like a hash table, we see the same thing.
Unlike a list where the elements are ordered, with a dictionary there is no order
to the elements. So when we print it out, they might appear in a different order
from the order that we put them in. We can use the indexing to look up
one of the elements. So now when we look up the value associated with hydrogen,
we get 1, and if we look up the value associated with carbon, we get 6.
What do you think is going to happen if we look up a value that's not in the dictionary?
So now we're looking up the value associated with lithium,
and what we get is an error. It's called a key error--key error. It says that element
is not in the dictionary. This is different from how we defined lookup for our hash table.
Right, we defined our lookup to return none when the element was not there.
The way the built-in dictionary type works is it gives us an error when it's not there.
If we don't want to get errors like that, we can use the in to see if an element is
in the dictionary. So the in behaves similarly to in did for lists.
We can say lithium in elements. That will evaluate to true if the key is in the dictionary,
false otherwise. So now hit evaluate, it's still false.
So I said that dictionaries were mutable. So we can add new elements.
And the way to add an element is just to use an assignment. So we'll add lithium
giving it a value of 3. Note that it was an error when we used an element like this
as a lookup when it's on the left side of an assignment. Well that's an update, so that
corresponds to the hash table update where lithium is the key, and 3 is the value.
We can add another element. Let's add another element. We'll add nitrogen.
And now when we look up nitrogen, we get the value that we assigned to nitrogen,
which is 8. It turns out that 8 is not actually the correct value. The atomic number
for nitrogen should be 7. So we can modify that value using another assignment.
That's again the same as our hash table update. It won't create a new key value
because the key nitrogen is already there, but it will update the value,
so now the value associated with nitrogen will be 7.
So we can see the first print, the value is 8, the second print, the value is now 7.